hi there and welcome back to the future
of documents i'm holt skinner and i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud
document ai comes with general
processors designed to process just
about any document you can throw at it
however machine learning models produce
the best results the more niche and
specialized they are so in this episode
we'll take a look at doc ai specialized
processors that are designed to handle
one or more specific document types
[Music]
currently document ai offers four main
categories of specialized processors
these are procurement identity lending
and contracts let's dive into each of
these and you can find the most
up-to-date list of specialized
processors in the cloud documentation
procurement processors are designed to
handle documents used for purchases and
payments these include a splitter
classifier to identify types of
documents even if there are multiple
documents in the same file an invoice
parser to process invoices in many
different formats an expense parser for
handling receipts and a utility parser
for handling utility bills
next up we have identity processors
these cover documents that can be used
to verify identity
for example
state and federal id cards passports or
other travel documents we also have an
experimental processor for detecting
fraudulent identity documents
next up we have lending processors these
are processors designed to handle
standard forms used in the united states
mortgage loan industry
currently these include a lending
splitter and classifier which identifies
documents that can be handled by the
lending processors and there are
dedicated parsers for standard
government forms like w-2s w-9s and
1099s
there are also processors for bank
statements payslips and more
last up we have contracts currently in
preview this solution allows for
extracting and understanding entities
that are specific to business contracts
such as agreement date effective date
renewal term and parties now that you've
got a taste for the specialized parsers
let's dive into what happens under the
hood when you make a process document
api call suppose you have a stack of
invoices from multiple vendors and
multiple formats or maybe a mortgage
packet with multiple tax forms and
statements
doc ai does some prep work it can handle
tilted and damaged pages no problem then
it reads in the raw text using ocr
next if you're using a splitter and
classifier it would identify the
separate documents here
then you can split and send each
document to the appropriate processor
now this is where i think one of the
most interesting differentiators occurs
with specialized processors you can get
the entities from the document in a
standard schema
for example with files like receipts and
invoices that don't really have a
standard format the model can detect
which text corresponds to the merchant
name line items taxes etc and returns
the values with the same key every time
let's look at another really neat
feature entity normalization
normalization can provide data such as
addresses dates and money in a standard
format this helps keep your data
consistent even with the many ways of
notating this information
let's look at an example of how
extraction works with specialized
processors in this case we'll use
driver's licenses from multiple states
each state driver's license represents
the id number a little bit differently
if we needed to extract this id field
using just ocr or the form parser we'd
need special handling for every single
format out there but that's the magic of
specialized processors they return a
uniform structure for a document type
regardless of the underlying layout
which makes post-processing much
easier now on to enrichment certain
specialized parsers integrate with the
google knowledge graph which can link up
the data in the document to real-world
entities
for example it can use data from google
maps to detect the supplier name address
on a receipt and connect it with the
full data provided by google maps
last but not least you can trigger a
human reviewer if your whole document or
certain entities do not meet a minimum
confidence value this lets you get that
last mile of accuracy let's take a look
at how this data is presented in the
document object structure
for specialized processors the extracted
information will be in the entities
field
type indicates the key from a
standardized schema like address or id
number
mention text is the raw text value for
the detected entity
confidence gives how sure the model is
that the values are correct
normalized value contains the normalized
and enriched data for supported
processors and properties contains any
nested entities you can explore the
document object structure and sample
responses in the cloud documentation
here's an example of detected entity in
this case we are analyzing an invoice
using the invoice parser for this sample
invoice we can see that the invoice
parser identified the receiver name and
address even though they aren't labeled
as such
this is mapping the data onto a
standardized schema for invoices
for the normalized values in addition to
capturing the raw text in the date field
the processor also recognizes the text
represents the 24th day of september in
the year 2019.
the unique part is that any invoice in
the world will get normalized dates in
this format no matter what date format
is used
for properties or nested entities we can
see that the invoice parser identifies
the line items and is able to separate
out the distinct components such as unit
price description and amount
[Music]
now it's your chance to try out document
ai specialized processors the code lab
linked in the description shows you how
to create the processors how to classify
documents and how to extract entities
for all specialized processors today we
discuss specialized processors and how
we can get deep insights from standard
document types
we explored a typical specialized
document workflow we explored how
specialized processors provide
standardized schemas and normalized
values to make post-processing easier
and we looked how to handle output from
a specialized processor in the document
object format
see you next time on the future of
documents and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
[Music]
you